you guys worth of today I'm going to
show you how to rank up already ranked
up get squad points fast in call of duty
ghosts now there's going to be a two
methods in this so I'm going to go
through them right now first one you see
on the screen now is the operations
operations like a change I think every
two weeks and yet five operations that
are generally not that hard like this
one it includes marathon always deadly I
sorry I can barely see it so
free-for-all on my Kimbo member and
something about guard dogs and so you
it's just running sprinting five miles
um killing people Oh with your main
weapon and your secondary weapon calling
guard dogs using the kimbo weapons and
just straight up winning free throw and
it's all easy and you get more and get a
ton of squad points from that also
there's some games i was like domination
kill confirmed but those to those
operations make sure you do them and
you'll keep getting tons of squad points
very good way of getting squad points
now the next week getting score points
you're going to want to go into squad
mode you're going to want to go to war
game this is kind of like combat
training I don't accept with with your
friends so I just want regular so just
pretty average and this will give you XP
even though it'll be you and your team
again see other people now make sure you
take note I've 9 score points now so I
find a group of people so put you six or
five other people and I think it's six
or five others or six in total it puts
you guys against a team of bots and
sohbats obviously on regular they're
easy to kill veteran the probably gonna
be pretty good but there are just some
box and you have to kill them and you
can get SWAT XP and points just as you
would in a normal game however there is
a catch to this there is a squad
you know limits in this so I got near
the end of the game so it's nothing like
super tiny but if you really don't
expect to get really wreck hard in this
because um like in terms of getting like
just you can't really do solve this
because I don't black ops we gave you
half of it and this there's just a
straight up cap so it's not like you're
getting half it's just a cap which I
guess I like the cap letters and jen's
old chances are i will encounter look
after more for direction and versus the
just getting half in combat training
that several you there right there i got
max XP which means all right that's it
bill it's all you got i'm pretty sure
the angries ends here yet infinity or so
that's everything I got I ended up
getting three squad points you'll see
the video at the end most of my god now
12 spa 20 verses and I'm here to start
those remember so yeah just to e really
easy way to rank up place squad war
games and do your operations so guys I
hope you enjoyed this if you did make
sure you leave a like rate comment or
subscribe romanticism
our guests
oh my god